no
ahora muy bienvenidos a una nueva
emisión de la entrevista de france 24 en
esta oportunidad vamos a hablar sobre el
racismo sistémico y la violencia
policial contra la población
afrodescendiente que impregna y marca la
vida de millones de personas en brasil y
es por eso que nos acompaña y saludamos
a sheila de carballo ella es abogada
representante jurídica de la coalición
negra por los derechos se trata de un
encuentro de entidades del movimiento
negro de todo brasil fue premiada en el
año 2020 por la organización de naciones
unidas como una de las afrodescendientes
más influyentes estamos ante una
referente para toda la región en lo que
es la lucha contra el racismo sistémico
y la violencia policial contra las
personas afrodescendientes ya la de
carvalho muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
muchas gracias y gracias a ustedes ya
bueno a pesar de ser la mayoría en un
país de cerca de 210 millones de
habitantes la población negra en brasil
enfrenta muchísimos obstáculos no y
violencia por sobre todo cómo se
manifiesta el racismo en brasil- sheila
así es mi marido es muy sutil
no es algo hecho abiertamente como fue
en otros países con la segregación de la
legislación pero tenemos no tenemos una
segregación formal pero tenemos una
segregación práctica en la práctica que
acontece es que las personas negras y
brasil son privados de ejercicio de su
ciudadanía entonces son las personas que
están en la línea de la pobreza son las
personas que son la mayoría de los
cárceles la mayoría de la situación de
exclusión económica social exclusión de
salud de educación pero no estamos
representados en los espacios de poder
no estamos en los parlamentos no estamos
representando en los gobiernos no
estamos representados en las distintas
instituciones de justicia tienes una
tendencia de segregar sin formalmente
segregar la práctica somos segregados de
apartados de nuestro ejercicio de la
ciudadanía claro eso es algo clave de la
que ocupen lugares de poder no que no
sean simbólicos que sean de poder
concreto ahora en brasil en fuerte
racismo sistémico también lo que son las
acciones de la policía verdad muchísimas
personas afrodescendientes mueren cada
año por la violencia que sufren por
parte de la policía maneja en algún tipo
de cifras yale en este sentido
si santiago la póliza de la policía de
veracidad es la póliza que más mata en
el mundo es especialmente personas
negras cuando vemos las cifras y
comparando con otros países la policía
en brasil mata 6 veces más personas
negras lo que la policía de los estados
unidos por ejemplo y tenemos una
población menor que la población de
estados unidos para tienes una idea sólo
en lo año pasado lo que se pasó fue más
de 6000 personas muertas por la acción
directa de la policía sin contar las
otras personas que son muertas por con
la relación de la policía pero de éstas
siempre no es contabilizada como tenemos
un caso acá en brasil sobre paraíso
porque es una
no afecta que acontecían a nada familia
de paraisópolis en la policía
hace hecho una intervención en este
evento en este evento más de 16 jóvenes
murieron en las de estos números no está
en la cuenta de la policía pero fueron
muertas fueron muertes causadas por la
policía y por qué considera usted que la
policía brasileña es tan agresiva con la
población afrodescendiente
tenemos en brasil la policía
militarizada una policía militar es una
póliza preparada para guerra no es una
policía preparada una policía preparada
para proteger nuestras comunidades sólo
cuando la policía hace sus
intervenciones son siempre en una
perspectiva violenta asesina abrupta y
sin respetar derechos porque fue una
policía instruida durante el período de
dictadura militar invención de la
policía hoy tenéis las mismas prácticas
que tenían las fuerzas de seguridad
pública la década de 60 y 70 cuando
vivíamos un período de restricción de
derechos y ahí esto que la policía la
metodología que la policía continúa
haciendo en nuestras comunidades sin ton
cuando hacíamos las intervenciones como
la contase son siempre es injusta y
negativa como si las personas por ser en
pueblos por no tener
el poderío económico no puede tener
derechos no tenemos hoy santiago una
decisión de la suprema corte de brasil
que prohíbe este tipo de acción de la
policía en las comunidades durante la
pandemia esta decisión de la suprema
corte está siendo desesperada por la
policía sólo un ojo de género entre
junio de 2020 y junio de 2021
tenemos un monumento de más de tres
veces un número de letalidad de la
policía me es muy cuesta decisión de la
suprema corte ahora llega este racismo
del cual estamos hablando es histórico
por supuesto lleva siglos no pero cómo
describiría usted la situación de la
población afrodescendiente hoy en brasil
en lo que es la era de jair bolsonaro no
que cambió con su llegada al poder
si hoy la situación está más difícil de
lo que estaban en de los últimos diez
años porque observamos una destrucción
de las políticas para equidad es hacia
la impresión solo que acompañe en acá en
brasil tenemos un pedido extra bajista
de 300 años que duró en nuestro país la
vibración
-puede del último el último país de que
abolió a la la escritura y listo se
planta delante porque teníamos 300 horas
de escribí dado tenemos señaló sin
ninguna política pública para invertir a
los males del pedido de escalabilidad
para revertir la desigualdad racial
liderada por escribir y las primeras
políticas para alcanzar y combatir el
racismo fue de la década del 90
impresión eso lo tenemos pocos años de
política efectiva
la transformación de nuestra sociedad
para una sociedad más justa una sociedad
sin racismo la sociedad que consiga
reconocernos el pasado para ver un otro
futuro y como avanzó de los gobiernos de
jair bolsonaro tenemos visto las
políticas creadas no tienen lo mismo
impacto y por tanto en el ámbito de la
educación tenemos pocos jóvenes negros
ingresando en la universidad quiero una
conquista importante que fue decente en
un movimiento negro no tenemos más
personas haciendo los espacios de poder
en brasil del que fue uno avanzó que
también conseguimos en los últimos años
y no tenemos más posibilidades de
conservar nuestro patrimonio histórico y
cultural porque alejar bolsonaro colocó
una persona que quiere destruir todo el
espacio de memoria lucha y existencia de
personas personas negras en la
institución
por hacer ese tipo de acción tan tiene
una una conexión directa de la
destrucción de nuestras políticas de tu
avanzó del racismo elevados o la
violencia policial la violencia de la
policía en los últimos años con un
gobierno revolucionario gobernó bossana
bolsonaro en específico el palo que
sobre violencia política la policía el
valor que tenía que matar como kaká
como si fuese un cierto tenía que es
matarlos está el papel de la policía es
mandar los pobres y negros entonces en
la situación muy complicada que acá
parece mucho aumento de la violencia de
la violencia dolores mimbres de ahora en
este contexto tan complejo y duro para
muchísimas personas que usted está
describiendo regla hay quienes hablan
incluso de un genocidio negro en brasil
coincide usted con este análisis
en cuanto a movimiento negro mirándonos
en cuanto un momento negro tenemos
defendido que vivimos un proceso de
genocidio negro no sólo aquí acá en
brasil santiago como en otras partes del
mundo reconocemos la existencia de un
proceso de genocidio del polo negro
porque el genocidio no es mal normal no
es sólo la violencia directa de
violencia la policía que te tira
nuestras nuestras vidas las vidas de
jóvenes las vidas de crianzas a través
de violencia de eso de esta policía
tenemos también un proceso de genocidio
cuando ausencia de políticas sociales
posibilita una nuestra muerte los
poquitos que vemos hoy con la pandemia
de ecovidrio en brasil esta pandemia
afectó de forma mucho más graves a la
población negra tenemos los mejores
índices de muerte los mayores índices de
impacto económico por compra de la
pandemia y esto todo está vinculado a
una política histórica de privación
de acceso a derechos pero la población
negra a esta ausencia de derechos de
hacer aceite de derecho a salud es
desatender hecho trabajos de derecho la
educación posibilitan y favorece un
proceso político de muerte es una
política de muerte que vivimos nombres y
borges para populación negre por eso
llamamos historia de genocidio sólo nos
queda un minuto pero no quiero dejar de
preguntarle qué sucede en términos de
racismo de discriminación y de violencia
contra las personas afrodescendientes en
brasil a nivel social no entre los
ciudadanos en lo que son las
interacciones diarias
las interacciones diarias de los
movimientos pero no me refiero a los hay
discriminación no hay violencias a nivel
social no ya no desde las instituciones
la policía por ejemplo el poder político
sino entre los ciudadanos
si esto acontece mucho acá en brasil a
continuar aconteciendo tenemos una élite
económica brasilera muy conservadora y
muy racista que no reconoce su propio
racismo tenemos una persona vestida que
fue frente a hembras y mucho interesante
que demuestra que el 90 por ciento de la
sociedad brasilera reconoce que en
brasil existe racismo pero 93 por ciento
de la sociedad afirma que nunca practicó
racismo las personas son incapaces
muchas veces de ver que lo que están
haciendo en una práctica de racismo para
el impacto sistémico para lindo impacto
que tenemos
de forma general en brasil el proceso de
relacionamiento y masa de legitimación
de la violencia de la policía de la
policía tenemos también estas prácticas
de lo cotidiano que envuelven procesos
de exclusión de las personas negras a
una persona está más teniendo a no
contratar a una persona negra lo que
contrataron no contrataron una persona
negra de que contratar a una persona
blanca para un puesto de trabajo por
ejemplo sheila de carl varios muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en entrevista
de france 24
gracias entidad con mucho gusto hablar
con usted por favor que sea usted ya
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]